now we of course just talking to the
shadow foreign secretary and we
Thornbury about Iran as well as her
Labour leadership ambitions we're joined
now by another candidate in that race at
least in land a she joins us now thank
you very much for coming to see us in in
the studio in London was it I just want
to start with Iran it's it's such a
concern so many of our viewers the
escalating tensions Donald Trump coming
up over the weekend saying that he could
potentially be targeting Iranian sites
if they respond now we've just hit his
song the tweet for iran's Foreign
Minister saying that that would be
effectively a war crime what's your view
on what's happening and so I think this
is a really really dangerous moment for
the entire world and for Britain in
particular what we need to see is a
prime minister who to be honest should
have already recalled Parliament in
order to explain what his strategy is
how he's going to work with our European
allies to try and deescalate the
situation and there's no question that
Soleimani is a dangerous individual
who's done some terrible terrible things
including putting down those
pro-democracy protests in Iran but
actually one of the the things that's
happened since Trump took this reckless
unilateral action a few days ago is that
we've seen those pro-democracy movements
falling apart that people getting behind
the Iranian regime I think we
potentially have a really really
dangerous and permanent situation that
could escalate into all-out war unless
the world leaders step up and speak with
one voice and try to make sure that we
take a multilateral approach to try and
calm this situation I mean you criticize
and Boston for not recalling Parliament
but really what can we actually do well
the Americans acted without warning us
clearly the UK government does want to
take the side of the Iranians well I
think that's a sign actually of how
little influence we now have in the
world we've had a decade of Ettore
government there has been smashing up
our relationships with our closest
allies and one of the things that brexit
has done that has been really really
damaging to the UK is that in the path
that Boris Johnson has pursued its left
us begging the US for a trade deal and
able to stand up and speak when we need
to be heard and we need to be counted
and I think what we need to hear from
the Prime Minister is that he's prepared
to do that and that he's prepared to
work with our European allies to make
that happen I mean there is there is a
model for this and there is a precedent
for this if you cast your mind back a
few years ago Barack Obama managed to
lead the world in negotiating a deal
that helped to make sure that Iran was
not a nuclear threat to the rest of the
world and that came about because of
years of diplomacy painstaking diplomacy
behind the scenes and world leaders
working together in order to restrain
what was quite a dangerous situation and
of course Donald Trump came in and and
smashed that to pieces by by pulling out
unilaterally but also had the sort of
support from the UK and we need to hear
from the Prime Minister that things are
going to be very different and I'm keen
to talk about your pitch for the Labour
leadership what you've come on the
programme of course to you talk about
and I also have a film with the same
question she didn't quite say yes do you
think that Terry Corbett was a good
leader of the Labour Party and I think
he did something profoundly important
for us and I want to say this because it
really matters to me and I think we're
in danger of learning the wrong lessons
from what has just happened
if you cash a man back to 2015 we were
knocking on people's doors in an
election saying to people who were
seeing the social fabric falling apart
who'd had five years of austerity who
were really really deeply worried about
the crumbling infrastructure and the
chances for their children and we were
saying to people we'll give you three
quid off your energy bill and we'll give
you 12 quid off your childcare and it
just didn't cut it people were looking
for deeper a much more fundamental
change and at the same time we were
saying to people if you give us
permission to to govern what we'll do is
we'll make sure that we you know we
don't let immigrants into this country
that we're not you know we don't raise
benefits too much that we're not paying
people a living wage all of those things
actually were really problematic for the
Labour Party because we are a party that
has to have the courage of our
convictions and where our values on our
sleeves so why did you just have your
worst election defeat since the 1913 it
trust Trust was the issue not the rudder
Liz I'm not the deep and fundamental
change that we're promising but trusts
we simple it says in our constitution
labour seeks the trust of the people to
govern and people didn't trust us one of
the things I really felt during the
election was that when the Tory said get
brexit done the more that we talked
about what was happening in the NHS the
crisis in the NHS rough sleeping mental
health the the chaos on the railways
which I know you're going to talk about
in a moment the the falling apart of the
bus network every time we talked about
those things people turned around to us
and said we agree with you but then in
order to deal with that you've got to
get brexit done and it gave a potency to
the Tory message hadn't understood you
say that the radicalism appealed but you
weren't trusted but those things are
linked omne he wouldn't trust it because
they thought it was too radical that it
was basically pie in the sky and I'm not
sure that they thought it was too
radical certainly when we were talking
to people for example about realising
the railways people felt it was a
no-brainer they couldn't believe that we
haven't been talking about it before but
what they really didn't trust us to do
was to get our priorities right when we
said that we would offer free broadband
I remember somebody in lis saying to me
I just want a functioning bus network on
them brakes they're clearly a big issue
something that you've and spoken about
as well and of course labor piled up
votes in some of these metropolitan
areas but lost heavily in leave voting
towns in particular somewhere don't know
you represent do you think that some of
your colleagues in the Labour Party
potentially in the Shadow Cabinet just
didn't get it
just didn't understand what people were
saying on doors in places like Wigan I
think there is definitely a disconnect
between the hierarchy of the Labour
Party and the country and people in
towns like mine who we took when brexit
happened we immediately went straight to
a discussion about free movement single
markets customs unions all of which are
very very important people right across
the country including in Wigan but what
we hadn't understood was that take back
control resonated like no other slogan
in my lifetime why did it resonate
because people lack the means to affect
change in their own lives and labour has
in recent years has become a very
paternalistic party we Commission
think-tank
survivors reports in central London we
sit behind desks in Westminster and
Victoria Street commissioning opinion
polls and focus groups and then we go
out and we tell people that we're going
to fix it
usually helps look down on some voters
in law well err even well I think that
easier Rachel I think that is a way of
patronizing people because actually
we've always been a movement that was
built by and for working people for
working people to effect change in their
own lives and to change the
circumstances of their own lives
the trains are a really good example of
that if you'd asked people in the north
of England what they wanted money spent
on in terms of transport they would have
started with buses and we just simply
haven't got it there was a moment when
Jeremy Corbyn stood up Prime Minister's
Questions a few years ago and talked
about buses and I remember this roar of
noise coming from the comment area in
London telling us that it was ridiculous
that they want to be Prime Minister
there was standing at the despatch box
talking about buses I tell you I got on
a train and went home and people were
saying thank God someone's talking about
our buses go change and I wonder and how
your message will go down with the labor
members of course who are the people
that you need if you're going to have a
chance of winning the leadership a poll
by you Gough and this week of Labor
members this is a percentage of first
preferences I mean your bottom there at
5% is that a bit disappointing no
because it's a name recognition poll and
I think Emily said before that and what
he doesn't do either is tell you how
many people don't know and haven't made
up their minds and actually people who
haven't made up their minds of the
majority in the labour party it's got a
long way to go they haven't of course
and and and it's but it's right that
labour members get to make their own
minds up and what I think this is
actually quite profoundly disrespectful
to try and bounce people into thinking
that there's only one candidate and one
candidate can win because our members
you know I was a councillor in London
before I before I before I got elected
to Parliament I lived in London for
eight years working for Centrepointe and
then the Children's Society with child
refugees and I spent a lot of time with
members our typical member now lives in
London cares deeply about poverty cares
deeply about winning a lot
because they want to effect real change
in their own communities and across the
country and I know that they care as
much about winning in Wigan as they do
in Walthamstow
and they want to have this debate and
they want to have this conversation and
they want to get it right ok and do you
have the number of MPs you need to get
on the ballot and so it's it's looking
very positive but I wouldn't in any
sense be complacent about that not quite
yet well I've got I've got to go I've
got to make the case and I think I think
we should should be ok but I don't want
to be complacent you know my colleagues
especially those who are elected when I
was a decade ago we've been through
three leadership contests in the last
decade and rightly we're all trying to
think very hard about getting this right
it's one of the reasons to be honest why
I did spend a few weeks after the
election just trying to work out whether
I was the right person to do this and
whether I should put myself forward and
when I went to ash field to listen to
the voters that we'd lost take it on the
chin it was quite hard to be honest and
it was quite heartbreaking and quite
emotional to listen to but when people
said we need a different sort of
leadership and a different sort of
leader and I thought that now is the
time to step up and that's the case that
I'm making to my colleagues